how's it going bros my name is pewdiepie
today we're gonna make some three by
threes i recently watched uh the boys at
the trash taste do this it was an old
thing i don't know if people still are
doing this but it reminded me of it i
remember people would post like their
nine favorite of something it was
usually video games i never actually
made one it feels like a tier list kind
of thing but for your favorite it was
almost like this is what defines me
look at this it even became like a meme
like it load my sweet three back to be
totally original they totally reflect my
true taste
i have good taste right look at me i
love these games and nothing else
i'm totally there i see your guy okay so
i wanted to try and make my 3x3 let's
start off with games one of my favorite
games again i don't like video games
i have nothing to put [ __ ] this is hard
i think i'll just do
the games that impacted me the most star
fox 64. i had never heard of this game
before but me and my parents we were on
holiday in spain and in spain you could
buy like really cheap video games it's
also where you can buy on the market
like those game boy cartridges i had
like 100 [ __ ] ripped off tour
ripped off uh illegal games on them and
it was just the best
i was allowed to pick up one game and i
randomly picked up star fox 64. i had no
idea what it was but it was such an
amazing time to play that game i can't
blow my mind i think it was one of those
games like you kids will never
experience this okay but or maybe you
will i'm sure you will i'm being a
little boomery here but i remember one
of the most fun things about video games
when you were a kid was like talking
about video games with your friends
and star fox was one of those games that
had a couple secrets in it and i
remember going to school and talking
about and being like what the different
stuff that we had discovered and like
the different levels and there's a
submarine level no you're kidding me
what i just have to go one left and then
right i'm like well i can't wait to come
home after school to try this out right
that was just so exciting and so much
fun and i think that's why you know star
fox it's in the right game this isn't
the right game it's not the best game i
know that but to me and the experience i
had with the game it's got to be up
there you know and the rumble pack that
was sick that was the first time i had
the rumble pack i also remember that
last boss is so cool
it clearly just ripped off star wars but
whatever
god it scared the [ __ ] get out of me
dude
[Laughter]
another thing i love about this game is
that all the lines are so iconic and
just burn into my brain
there's one more to go
all range mode all aircraft reports
we're heading for awkward we're heavy
for what dude sleepy's was the best i
[ __ ] love sloppy thought you could
hide from me eh don't forget me do
something are you okay data analysis
complete here it comes ah i'm hit don't
worry flippy's here
we're just the one hey einstein i'm on
your side never forgetting hey einstein
i'm on your side the amount of time this
[ __ ] would tell me that which was the
best line though the best line in the
whole game is can't let you do that
stuff but
this blew my mind i was like this is the
cold this is the oldest thing
andros has ordered us to take you down
happy long time no see
yeah i don't know what i can't explain
why i thought this was so cool i was
like
i can't let you do that starbucks
this scene is ingrained to my childhood
that's so funny like i'm sharing that
experience with other people and i don't
know
why i think there was some background
that like he's the one that killed your
dad and then he shows up out of nowhere
inside
can't let you do that stop let you do
that
hell
[ __ ]
yeah
i realized
now there's so many games that come to
mind i gotta put donkey kong country two
on this [ __ ] i got i put this [ __ ]
under the
oh my god this game and this does not
suit the 3x3 the 1x1 square formula but
whatever okay i talked about this before
but so i i wasn't allowed to have a game
console i don't know why like my mom
loved playing video games i guess she
did it more for herself she's like no
we're not having a game console she
cracked eventually all right
but it meant that whenever i was sick we
would rent a game console so being sick
was like the greatest thing in the
entire universe for me because then i
would always pick a donkey kong games i
love them but the one i enjoyed the most
was donkey kong country 2 diddy
consequence i replayed it not long ago
and it's still a legitimately good
platformer
and the thing was you could play two
players within
i don't know if that was a common thing
back in the day i don't think it
necessarily was so to be able to play
like a a game with your friend no i
think that was pretty common but i just
remembered this was like the first game
i played that was together with someone
else i would play with my sister i would
play with my mom
it was just so fun oh i remember even
when i wasn't sick anymore my mom kept
the console rented and then she would
play it in her bedroom
and then if she got stuck on a level i
would have to come in and play with it
oh
it's so funny how all these like sound
effects are so ingrained in you but
especially
that soundtrack i [ __ ] i think this
is the greatest soundtrack of any video
game
i already know which song i love
[Laughter]
ah this one
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
takes me back man
[Laughter]
it's so good there's so many more good
uh songs on this oh yeah chill now
literally just like re-uploads them and
they got a ton of views
so so so good
so good
beautiful checkpoint get done with
school and i can finally focus on
youtube man wait what what is with the
checkpoint meme people are like updating
how they're doing based on this video
what the [ __ ] is this meme feeling
lonely lately
okay my checkpoint uh came from the
sound yeah this game [ __ ] slaps i had
a great childhood no complaints what the
[ __ ] am i looking at uh another obvious
one for me is
the game
tibia
i talked about this game before the best
version was clearly 7.6 i think it
looked like this this is what the
[ __ ] game looked like can you believe
it can you
anything uglier i guess this game was
kind of like runescape but from the
overhead perspective only and i played
with my friends
and it's probably the most fun i've ever
had in video games playing this [ __ ]
game because it was complete anarchy you
could do whatever you wanted in this
game you could [ __ ] people over so bad
and as a young kid playing it you
obviously got [ __ ] over but you [ __ ]
over so many people it is so funny i
still remember like these memories of
just
making people
get so pissed off as like the best part
of my channel
oh man what could you do i'm sure
there's the same scams like in runescape
but like you could trade items with
people and back in the day lee would
have to like write in a public chat or
something be like okay i'm trading this
item and you would hope someone else
would see it and then reply and then you
have to be like okay which city are you
in uh the mapping tv is [ __ ] huge for
them like oh i'm in thais oh i'm in
venor okay i'll come to you but then you
have to pay extra no no it's fine i'll
come to you don't pay extra or whatever
and then so much to organize just to get
a [ __ ] item right but it was part of
the game so finally you make it to each
other and you're supposed to make the
trade and what you could do to scam
people was you take like uh i don't even
remember uh
right this item you take that that's a
low level scam though so someone would
trade you warhammer you don't even get
that much money out of it it's worth 1
200. so you would trade trade this item
with people i remember doing this a lot
because it's easy to do on a low level
oh you have to be level 50 to use it now
oh what a shame
they nerfed it such a good like early
whatever what the [ __ ] am i talking
about okay so someone would trade you
this and you would trade it with them
and then it would pop up a window like
you are trading this with this you see
their money and they see your war hammer
and then you click cancel and they're
like oh sorry i clicked uh trade again
and then you trade again and it shows up
warhammer and they show the money and
it's like oh [ __ ] [ __ ] up clicked
cancel again and then the third time
you trade battle hammer instead
it's garbage worth nothing and since
they're just ready to click yes and they
look kind of similar it's a great way to
trick people uh out of their money
there's like a million things like that
you can do in tibia
and the ways to steal people's money
threaten them
extort them for money
it was the best i'm annoying now imagine
how annoying i was playing this game as
a child you can i was the worst
i could talk about memories from this
game for days and uh i'll forever be
grateful the tibia for what it was now
it seems like it's just pay to win it's
a kind of shame i don't know if you can
put dota 1 on the list
because it wasn't a game it was like a
mod from warcraft 3 the frozen throne oh
yeah i would play the sniper a lot he
was so fun
such an easy character when was this
like when did doda came on 2003 we were
playing this uh me and my friends in
sweden we would go to these net cafes
i guess i'll have to put this game on
technically this wasn't the game but it
was a mod from this game so yeah we
would go to net cafes and we would play
this all together like a party of what
is it four or five i don't remember and
we would play it against either online
or against other people in the neck cafe
and just yelling at each other all in
the same room playing games together on
a computer you know that wasn't possible
without neck cafes back in the day not
everyone had a computer like that at
home and with stable internet especially
was just like uh not a thing and now
it's huge not in sweden surprisingly
because everyone's got their own
computer but in other countries like
korea and i don't [ __ ] know i just
remember that being so much fun and and
like on a saturday call up your friends
we would all go to town to a neck cafe
to play dota together just amazing
memories so for the dota when that came
up i remember
dota stopped being popular and some
other some other clones of dota came out
i know there was some problem with the
lawsuit and
you know because it was a mod and the
mod of the game was becoming better than
the game itself and it was kind of
awkward
i don't remember exactly what happened
but i remember league of legends coming
out right and we were all laughing our
asses off 2009 how old was i then 20
yeah i was 20. [ __ ] i wasn't that young
what the [ __ ] is that possible well
anyway we i remember when league of
legends first came out we were like
there's no way this garbage is gonna
become popular are you kidding me it
looks like [ __ ] trash look how
colorful and dumb it is that was like
the biggest game of all time it's like
oh
guess we were wrong
i never played much moba after that but
i mean yeah moba is huge now everyone
everyone's probably played at some point
i think i had my fun with it like i
don't really see a reason to jump into
it no mobile will never be as fun as
when we played it all together neck
cafes and sweden that was such a good
[ __ ] time
clearly there's like some sort of
interaction with a lot of these games
it's not just how i experience them but
it's how i experience them with other
people with friends or family i think
that's kind of cool like that's what
left more of an impact i just noticed a
pattern i'm trying to think of like
games now that i played on my own that
kind of blew my mind i think there's the
youtube ones that i played that what i
will get into but for i'm trying to
think pre youtube still because i can
easily just slap minecraft on there i'm
trying to think well i guess now is a
good time to add minecraft obviously i
gotta add minecraft this game
i had one of the most fun times on my
youtube channel thanks to this game so
i'll forever be grateful for it for sure
like all the excitement for a new
episode for this game and all the
excitement for me looking forward to
recording the episode as well it's the
[ __ ] best feeling in the world man
so good that week when i literally got
married
beat the ender dragon at the same time
how lit was that dude that's the
highlight that's a peak for sure
it's also a game that i played before i
did youtube it was actually the first
thing i ever recorded i don't have the
original footage of it but it was kind
of ironically like i kind of started my
youtube at the same time minecraft
became big and then i avoided playing it
for so long just because i thought it
was like too popular and kind of cringey
and then i realized hey it's actually a
[ __ ] amazing game and i love being
able to share that with you guys as well
online uh now i don't know like i played
it so much
if there's new updates i'll obviously
check it out but i don't know
did anyone ever play this game favorite
third-party developer was for the
nintendo 64. they'll probably tell i
feel like this could easily be on the
list it's just that uh i'm not convinced
this is one of those game i i love
it's so [ __ ] weird and trippy
yeah it's one of those underrated games
that legitimately was really good i just
don't have like that personal connection
to it really it feels like one of those
games you would put on your three by
three to be like hey look at me guys i
get this underrated game
yeah yeah it's definitely there was
another one like that on the 64.
pokemon snap didn't come raising dude
like any game on the nintendo six
performer it's almost worth it ben you
can zooey oh my god
star x64
legend of zelda oh golden eye was so
that could easily be on the list could
easily be on the list it's just not
there i don't have that connection in my
soul like i do with all these other
titles you know even though amazing
games mario kart 64 same super mario 64
same legend of zelda same this is not
fully there
the heart isn't fully there man oh my
god how could i even forget or even a
second i had the blue one i wanted the
red one but i got the blue one
and oh boy
what was it about this game that just
blew everyone's mind i don't know the
whole like going on an adventure and
then proving your channel and up for the
challenge and all the gyms
you know getting that emotional
attachment to your pokemons
get to role playing this really and the
anime that came out at the same time i
think as well just gave this such a
heavy
impact oh my god this game was so good
and another great part about this game
was that everyone was playing it
like every kid in sweden had a game boy
loaded up with the either the red or the
blue pokemon on it right and also
another part of it was i had one of
these cables i convinced my mom to buy
it so you could play
against other people so their pokemon
against your pokemon which to me was
like the coolest thing because i'm like
this is what pokemon is all about you
battle each other with your pokemons so
i would go around with my [ __ ] cable
and challenge all these dumbass kids
who weren't ready for a random kid to
challenge them
and i of course would have been like the
most annoying uh cheekiest setup of only
like i would have all the psychic
pokemon and just use sleep over and over
again and i was like that's so cool i'm
like one of those gym people because
they only use one set of pokemon and i'm
like the psychic pokemon guy and i sleep
there and then they die and it's awesome
and they can't do anything
you fools
so fun [ __ ] house such a good game
all right we only got three spots left
what's it gonna be
obviously amnesia the doctor said there
just wasn't any other horror game out
there like this game and for someone
that had no experience with horror games
or even barely was able to watch horror
movies to go through this game
was just such an
insane experience in itself i never been
so scared in my life and i probably will
never be so scared in my life
it was also at the time when i was
starting off youtube i was still in
university and i was really struggling
on what i wanted to do but i thought you
know it might be fun to record myself
playing this game it's not really a
thing that people do did at the time it
wasn't popular but i thought okay well
if i have to go through and play this
game that i'm clearly way too scared of
playing i might as well record myself
playing it i think this is the part
where i was the most scared ever
i'm so scared
the video that started it all the
beginning of a legend
what a win it wasn't like a huge thing
for my channel right away i was still
fairly small for a very very very very
long time okay but amish obviously
became the thing that got my channel
started but it wasn't like i played an
environment huge this was one of those
things i just moved out of my parents
house at the time and i would wake up at
like 4 a.m and load up amnesia and start
recording it it was a weird time but i
loved it good memories we got two more
i'm gonna fill this with i'm asking
reddit
which one they like outlast classic
pewdiepie last of us
last of us is almost worthy
it just isn't
that well is really close actually such
a shame because i hated the second one
i'm close i'm close to putting it on
there actually
just because it was at the time where i
was becoming the biggest channel on the
site and it was such an engaging
experience it was one of the biggest
playthroughs out i'll probably ever have
after amnesia i don't know i'm not like
a huge fan of the game it's more like
my experience with the game and sharing
it with you guys online i don't know if
it's worthy actually we'll put it there
for now dude we've done some crazy
playthroughs on this channel i know i
forgot one
this is
yeah
yeah i don't care
i don't care i love this game
i love this game i had so much [ __ ]
fun playing this game it was such a good
shooter absolutely yeah no regrets this
was the kind of game i played before
youtube let me log into my old steam
account and see how many hours i have in
this game
it's not that bad just 40 days of my
life roughly
i'm removing less of this sorry oh
[ __ ] bully it was so good
any of the dark souls games could be
good too i love those i don't know
i think i know
sorry i'm a boomer this is legitimately
just an amazing [ __ ] game okay
i you can play it now today and it has
aged perfectly okay it's still amazing
one of my favorite single player games
it probably this or bioshock one but i
think half like two is better there you
go there's my three by three i didn't i
think i'm i'm satisfied i'm actually
happy with it i didn't think i would be
what the [ __ ]
this is so weird to look at
dude thank you for letting me rant about
my own reminiscence since what are your
experiences i want to know let me know
if you shared any of my uh my childhood
or gaming experiences let me know what
they are thanks for watching see you
tomorrow breakfast
you thought it was gay
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make memes
inside tuber simulator add some of our
patented stickers in there stickers our
emotions memes our emotions express your
emotions with me
share them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows
maybe i'll review your memes the
greatest honor of all time full circle
baby download it make a meme
we need subtitles on this